today marks the end of the first week of
hybrid learning for students in the
clark county school district
superintendent dr jesus jarris says he's
confident the first week went smoothly
but we've learned about some positive
coronavirus cases the i-team's vanessa
murphy is live at a local elementary
school in henderson with more on what
was addressed vanessa
we've learned eight school staff members
have been have tested positive for
covid19
over the past week and some families
were notified so
children could quarantine and i want to
be clear this is not specific to this
school
this is district-wide assistant school
superintendent dr brenda larson-mitchell
says
some of the staff members were working
remotely and some were back on school
campuses for hybrid learning
we obtained a list of the schools
affected and we put that at eight
newsnow dot com for you
with preparation and planning we have
strict protocols in place
and we were able to implement those and
give direction and provide direction to
the school and communicate with our
parents and our families
the district reports that 54 percent of
students are participating in full-time
distance learning
still now hybrid learning is now offered
for pre-k
through third grade on march 22nd it is
offered for grades
6 9 and 12. that expands on april 6 for
grades
7 8 10 and 11 and then all students
pre-k through grade 5 can return to the
classroom full-time
school leaders say they will still have
to follow social distancing rules
so some students will not be able to
return to the classroom
if the demand is higher than what they
can
accommodate they will have to prioritize
students
and one example is students who already
hybrid learning
will be prioritized vanessa murphy 8
news now